today on the Matt Walsh show CBS airs a
Satanic ritual in prime time during the
Grammys last night we'll talk about our
culture's continued slide into outright
Satanism also the Chinese balloon Saga
finally comes to an end but was the
whole story just one big diversion
tactic a medical researcher admits that
he was wrong about kovid should we
forgive and forget and in our daily
cancellation I provoked enormous
controversy with my provocative claim
that men want loving and appreciative
wives people are very upset about this I
will address the controversy today all
of that and much more the Matt Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
despite the U.S blowing through 31.4
trillion dollar debt ceilings in January
the leftist White House still refuses to
reduce spending if you're tired of the
government playing games with your
savings and your retirement plan then
you need to get in touch with the
experts at Birch gold today for over 5
000 years gold has withstood inflation
geopolitical turmoil and stock market
crashes now you can own gold and attack
sheltered retirement account Birch gold
makes it easy to convert an IRA or 401K
into an IRA and precious metals text
Walsh to 98 98 98 to claim your free
info kit on gold and then talk to one of
their precious metal Specialists with an
A plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews you can
trust Birch gold to help protect your
savings today Tex Walsh to 98 98 98 and
protect yourself with gold today that's
Walsh to 98 98 98 today
well the most shocking thing about the
Grammy Awards last night was that
apparently they're still doing the
Grammy Awards the second most shocking
thing is that from what I read this
morning they gave the song of the year
honor to Bonnie Wright who's a talented
and Soulful musical artist who actually
deserves the recognition she was able to
go up to the stage by herself to accept
the award because she wrote and
performed the song herself compare that
to say Beyonce who needs 97 songwriters
and 3 000 producers to manufacture her
music through an assembly line like
process but Bonnie Raitt is not the
person we're supposed to be celebrating
today our adulation is supposed to be
focused primarily on the singers Kim
Petras and Sam Smith they're both white
males but their win is the in the best
pop Duo category supposed to be a
victory for diversity and inclusion as
these are white males who self-identify
as something other than white males Sam
Smith claims to be non-binary while Kim
Petras identifies as a transgender woman
quote unquote here is a Petras accepting
the award and congratulating himself for
his historic achievement listen
Sam graciously wanted me to accept this
award because I'm the first transgender
woman to win this award
and and I'm sorry
thank you
um and I just want to thank
um all the incredible transgender
Legends before me who kicked these doors
open for me so I could be here tonight
well he's not the first male to win the
award he's probably not the first male
who dresses like a woman to win it but
he is the first male winner who claims
to be a woman and this is supposed to be
a historic achievement but here's a
perhaps more interesting point about Kim
Petras born Tim Petras he got gender
reassignment quote-unquote surgery at
the age of 16. in fact back in 2009 the
then aspiring pop star did a media tour
where he was celebrated for Having the
courage to live as his true self with
the aid of you know genital mutilation
and drugs and all the rest of it here's
a clip from an interview on a British
talk show back then listen
but it's not just the scale of her
ambition that makes young Kim very
extraordinary well Kim was born Tim and
is believed to be the youngest person in
the world to have had a sex change and
she joins us now and it's lovely to have
you here thank you thank you very much
indeed so
um so you're born in 1992 in Cologne in
Germany right and we've we've met a
number of of people who've been in a
sort of similar position who've sat
where you're sitting and all have said
from the word go there was no question
that they knew precisely what they were
they were trapped in the wrong body
that's right um I always knew it you
know when I was a little kid I was
always wanting pink dresses Barbie
everything
well there you have it you like pink
dresses you like Barbie
clearly proof that he was born in the
wrong body whatever the hell that's
supposed to mean exactly but his doctors
couldn't give him a new body because
such a thing is impossible you can't
have a new body you only have the body
that you're born with all they could do
is
mutilate the one and the only body that
he has or will ever have and that's what
they did at the age of 16. now keep this
in mind when the left claims that these
procedures aren't being performed on
minors one of the biggest now Grammy
Award to winning pop stars in the
country is a male who had his gender
reassigned or confirmed according to the
updated euphemisms as a minor and this
was back in 2009 when the medical
guidelines were stricter than they are
today though obviously they were not
nearly strict enough even then now the
song that won the award is aptly titled
Unholy and the two award-winning males
performed it for the assembled audience
after they won this award Madonna who uh
with each passing day comes to more and
more resemble the creepy puppet from the
the saw franchise introduced The Duo who
then launched into a blatantly demonic
performance
the whole thing was designed to look
like some kind of satanic sex ritual
with fire and devil horns and BDSM
themes and Sam Smith dressed like Satan
here's a clip and make sure you pay
attention all the way to the end of this
clip watch
[Music]
[Applause]
the Satanic ritual brought to you by
Pfizer little two on the nose I have to
say
now needless to say the main reason they
went all in with the campy Party City
devil costumes and demonic imagery and
all of that is that they want attention
Sam Smith is the same guy who just
released a music video that shows him
parading around at a piss orgy drinking
urine he's uh desperate to be noticed
and will do literally whatever it takes
he certainly can't rely on the quality
of his music to speak for itself I mean
putting aside The Satanist stuff just
listen to the lyrics from that Unholy
song that we just heard a clip of
lyrics mommy don't know Daddy's getting
hot at The Body Shop doing something
Unholy he sat back while she's dropping
it she'd be popping it yeah she put it
down slowly
this is just absolute brain rotting
stupidity these are alleged artists who
have no art to offer nothing to say no
Talent no creativity
and so they can only try to shock us
there's always been art with immoral
messages the difference is that in
modern times our immoral art is produced
by the most tiresome collection of
monotonous talentless idiot hacks to
ever walk the earth
as I said about Sam Smith's pea guzzling
music video this stuff is indeed
offensive and gross and disgusting Etc
it's all of that
but it's also utterly tedious and boring
these depraved attention mongers can't
even manage to be offensive in an
interesting way
instead they simply recycle the same
shock tactics over and over again
and we've seen it all by now
as it turns out there are only so many
ways to be a satanic after a while
it gets repetitive and and we are way
past that point today
but with that said even if these
degenerate pop stars are just vying for
our attention in the most obvious
overdone ways because they have the IQ
and creative Talent of a paper plate
there's still a certain significance to
the fact that a major broadcast network
uh you know broadcast a Satanic ritual
live on air last night
I think it'd be a mistake to ignore this
development completely instead we should
I think focus on it for long enough to
learn the lesson that this event can
teach us two lessons really
first
the left's cultural agenda is to tear
down and desecrate all that you love and
hold as sacred they have no ideas of
their own they have no plan beyond the
the destruction
that's why they borrow from Christianity
even while they try to ridicule it they
have to in effect sit on the same limb
they're trying to saw off the tree they
can't stand on their own they have
nothing they don't have their own
platform
it's an agenda motivated by pure hatred
and resentment they don't even know why
they hate what they hate but they do
hate it and their hatred drives them to
destroy
second and I think maybe most important
point
is that leftism is satanism
there's a reason they rely so heavily on
satanic imagery and all that kind of
stuff they are all literally satanists
just not for the most part theological
sadness
that's an important distinction here
there are some theological satanists out
there who actually worship the devil
outwardly you know
um but these people they don't consider
themselves and most leftists they
certainly don't consider themselves to
be worshiping a being called Satan
rather they're worshiping what Satan
worshiped which is the self
the story of Satan is that he refused to
worship and serve God choosing instead
to worship and serve himself and the
modern leftist has made the same choice
leftism is the worship of the self
it is the elevation of the self
and the wants and desires of the self
especially the sexual wants and desires
above everyone and everything else
almost all modern pop music is an Ode to
this idea pop stars are
singing praises to the gospel of
self-worship which is to say that most
of it is satanic
yes there's something that Media Matters
can pull most pop music is satanic
because it is it is is about promoting
the worship of the self
it's just that it's usually not so
explicit about it
but I think it's probably better that
they are explicit so that people can see
all this stuff for what it really is
and respond accordingly to it
now let's get to our headlines
if you own a business the past few years
have been a bumpy ride from coveted
lockdowns to bite inflation you could
probably use a break an innovation
refunds can help with that if your
business has five or six five or more
employees and manage to survive covid
you could be eligible to receive a
payroll tax rebate for up to twenty six
thousand dollars per employee that is
not alone uh there's no payback it's a
refund of your taxes that's all it is
all you gotta do is go to re
getrefunds.com their team of tax
attorneys are highly trained in this
little-known payroll tax refund program
and have already returned one billion
dollars to businesses and they can help
you too they do all the work no charge
up front they simply share a percentage
of the cash that they get for you
businesses of all types could qualify
including those who took PPP non-profit
and even those that had increases in
sales see if your business qualifies for
ERC assistance in about eight minutes
all you do is go to getrefunds.com click
on qualify me and answer a few questions
this payroll tax refund is only
available for a limited amount of time
don't miss out go to getrefunds.com
getrefunds.com
all right as you can uh here got a
little bit of a cold so uh I hope I
don't lose my voice again as I did a few
months ago although I say I hope I don't
lose my voice but maybe I hope that I do
lose it because it was kind of nice last
time I have to admit because I felt you
know things you lose your voice you feel
fine other than that
but for my job I have to talk because if
I lose it I just it means I get to take
a vacation and there's no pressure to
talk at all because I can't so
we'll see what happens but we'll start
with this
from the daily wire the conclusion of
this Saga that many people were were
fascinated by I have to confess I wasn't
nearly as interested as most people seem
to be
um and in fact I I
never would have guessed that that they
could get like a four day news cycle out
of a balloon flying in the sky I didn't
I didn't guess that one now granted
there have been other balloon-centric
news Cycles before there was the it was
a there's a kid in a balloon or
something
there's some there's some sort of ended
up being a hoax the balloon boy that was
a thing right or did I just dream that
was that that was a thing thing okay and
was it was the kid actually in the
balloon or were they making that up the
whole time
it was made up okay so there was there
was that new cycle that was a little bit
more interesting
I think than this
but here's the latest from the daily
wire the Chinese foreign minister
responded to the U.S military shooting
down at spy balloon over the Atlantic
Ocean on Saturday by claiming without
evidence that the balloon was a civilian
object and that the country was
extremely upset by the action
civilian object
that was a it was a balloon from from a
child's birthday party that just uh went
up in the sky you know they were having
a barbecue out and one of the balloons
just went up and then it floated across
the Pacific and over Alaska and down
into the continental United States it
happens you know it does happen
an F-22 Raptor took out the Spy balloon
with one air-to-air uh a9x Sidewinder
missile that was fired at an altitude of
approximately 58 000 feet decision to
shoot down this Bible and came after
presidential Biden allowed the balloon
to fly thousands of miles over the
continental U.S during the last several
days
the statement claimed China expresses
its strong dissatisfaction in protest
against the US's use of force to attack
civilian unmanned aircraft the Chinese
side has repeatedly informed the U.S
side after verification the Airship is
for civilian use and it entered the U.S
due to force uh major it was completely
an accident
the statement continued China clearly
asked the U.S to handle it properly in a
calm professional and restrained manner
a spokesman for the U.S Department of
Defense also stated that the balloon
will not pose a military or personal
threat to ground Personnel China will
resolutely Safeguard the legitimate
rights and interests of relevant
companies while reserving the right to
make further necessary reaction
foreign
maybe this is the thing that actually
starts the the uh the hot war between
China and the U.S is over a balloon it's
all it's always what you don't expect
Biden tried to take a Victory lap over
the weekend after the Spy balloon was
shot down claiming that he ordered the
Pentagon to shoot it down on Wednesday
as soon as possible the decision was
made to not shoot it down over the land
because uh debris could cause damage
when falling to the ground
they also claim that from what I've read
they claim that they jammed the signal
of the Spy balloon
while it was flying over the U.S and
then they waited till it was over the
ocean they shot it down and now they're
going to try to collect the remnants of
it so they can take it and study it and
whatever get whatever information they
can can out of it
um the My Administration also claimed
over the weekend that there were
multiple instances I think they said
three instances where a spy balloon uh
floated above the United States while
Trump was in office and he didn't do
anything about it so that was that that
was their official response oh yeah well
what about him
he did it two
I have to say
first of all number one I am sticking
with my theory that really it was aliens
um there's there's nothing to hang that
theory on at this point but that's what
I choose to believe about this and that
certainly makes it more interesting to
me
the second thing is if it wasn't aliens
on the on the radical chance that it
wasn't aliens
then uh you know did Biden respond the
right way did the by Administration
respond the right way to this balloon
thing no I tend to agree with most
people that that as I said on Friday
when we talked about this that he he
should have shot it down the the first
chance that they saw it and considering
the fact that it floated over Alaska and
then down across the United States it
was over Montana when we first heard
about it these are not heavily populated
areas and uh you could have easily shot
it down and you know in an area where
the debris is not likely to cause any
harm to any any people
but they claim that they jammed the
signal wait until it's over the ocean
then they took it out
and maybe they did maybe I I can't say
they didn't do that
that and if that is what they did okay
that's that's that that might be a fine
way of responding
to me though the issue is
that after a while the whole story
starts to seem like a distraction
that's kind of the camp that I end up in
here
it's a it's a it's a very strange thing
that
you know in the middle of last week they
make this big announcement about the
balloon and then that's and then that's
what we're focusing on that's what the
news media is focused on for days and
days is this balloon
which they now tell us it was never a
big deal they jammed the signal they
took it down they always had it under
control again I there's no reason to
believe the bite Administration on
anything that it says but I for for all
I know that could be true I don't know I
I don't believe it
I don't believe anything they say on
their own word
but I also don't know
I I really don't know what the deal was
with this balloon
um
but the real question I have is like why
was that the thing they wanted us
talking about for days
and it's just a good practice you know
whenever the media is pointing your
direction over here it's always good to
think well what's over there that they
don't want us talking about
especially when they're pointing us over
here and say look at that look at look
at the big balloon in the sky
look at that let's talk about that for
three days
foreign
and then they move on from
talk about it for three four days is how
it was never a big deal anyway
let's let's go back to what we were
talking about what we were talking we
weren't talking about anything before
right okay well let's
reset the new cycle and uh we'll find
something else
that's that's my question what were they
trying to distract us from
post-millennial has this story a
trans-identified male who claims to be
the mother of two trans kids testified
before a Minnesota house Committee in
favor of Minnesota becoming a trans
Refuge state for people seeking
out-of-state medical sex changes
the biological male has a trans partner
as well as two children who are involved
in gender identity Amber described the
torrent of damaging ill-informed and
outright malicious legislation being
introduced across the country as reason
for Minnesota to become a safe haven for
transgender individuals and parents
seeking experimental sex changes for
their children
so we've been following this law in
Minnesota and there have been there have
been several days of testimony and this
is the latest with this um
male who identifies as a female let's
just watch a little bit of this
testimony
my name is Amber mom I use she her
pronouns
uh I'm a member of the Saint Cloud Hive
of the parents and allies of trans youth
the transgender movement for Liberation
and a member of the tea time support
group run by the aliveness project
I am also a proud transgender woman but
more importantly I am the mother of two
wonderful transgender and gender
expansive children
I drove down from Saint Cloud to show my
support for house file 146 and thank
representative Finke for introducing
such an important and life-saving Bill
to protect trans children and their
families at such a critical time for us
as you may be aware there's a torrent of
damaging ill-informed and outright
malicious legislation being introduced
across the country targeting transgender
and gender expansive people broadly but
trans children in particular
it is our daily experience to be forced
to keep track of which state is safe for
us to visit
Minnesota has been overall very
accepting and supportive of our family
but even then we don't feel 100 safe and
assured that we will be able to get the
gender affirming care that both of my
kids need and deserve very recently an
amendment was proposed to house file 16
with in Minnesota which bans children's
conversion therapy in an attempt to ban
Essential Health Care for transgender
children this happened in our state
because of this my trans partner and I
frequently discuss plans to flee the
country if these targeted hateful bills
keep being introduced or passed I never
thought that it would come to this but
here we are
positive but keep keep this image up on
the screen
of this uh
right everyone once again this is
someone that everyone looks at this
person said well that's a that's a woman
all right
certainly
I mean I don't I don't I don't even say
this as an insult to me he looks a
little bit like the uh he's like a pink
version of the what's the blue guy from
from uh McDonald's
it was a little bit like that guy but
but but in pink
Grimace yeah it's a little bit like a
pink Grimace again not I don't mean as
an insult I mean that's that that's a
look that some people enjoy
but I do think it's interesting
that this individual Okay so
this person is married to a trans person
and then
what do you know
uh they also have two children who who
just so happen to be trans
but remember there's no social contagion
aspect of this
and and uh well certainly no one is
turning children trans or encouraging
them to be trans or planting these ideas
in their head
no one is doing that that's a conspiracy
theory
and yet yet what do you so often find
you so often find that uh so-called
gender expansive adults tend to have
quote unquote gender expansive children
I just feel I mean
you feel horrible for these kids
what chance do they have in the world
and that's what stops me from you know
he says that well we're gonna I want to
flee the country
well if if he himself flees uh and and
he's doing that you know in part in
response to some of the laws that were
that that are being passed around the
country but then I consider that another
great benefit of those laws
except that he has kids he'd bring with
him
and they're the real victims in all this
but also remember something else that
this person right here that is a real
woman and not only that he's a realer
woman than real women
at least that's uh what this person on
Tick Tock and lives at Tick Tock posted
this a few days ago here's someone on
Tick Tock explaining that uh exactly
that the quote-unquote trans women are
more womanly than actual women listen
but I'm just gonna be honest with you
guys I am tired of turfs making a
mockery of real women oh white you were
born with ovaries you bleed every month
you have XX chromosomes yeah that's cute
tell me what other external factor that
doesn't apply to all of you
defines you the end of the day you're
out here thinking that trans women are
making a mockery of you when it's the
exact opposite you are pretending that
you know that you're a woman when the
only people here who know that for sure
are the ones who have put in the work to
understand themselves the trans women
you have put zero work in actually
understanding yourself you are only a
woman because everybody else around you
looked at the same external factors that
you look at and said um seems like woman
Behavior to me and you went all right
the only person making a mockery of
Womanhood is you because you do not
fully understand what makes you a woman
stop harassing trans women I don't even
identify as a woman and I'm more of a
woman than you it's okay to be scared of
success men but don't take it out on
people who aren't even a threat
maybe there's a term that we should
introduce into the dialogue here which
is uh trans supremacist
because that's what you hear there
and that's in fact most trans activists
that's actually what they are they're
trans supremacists
um they they don't just it no it's it's
they don't want to be included
as as a woman they don't want to be
merely included
they want to be at the top of you know
the pecking order
okay they they want to be celebrated as
not just a woman or one woman among many
they're the best women of all
and that's actually what they want
because the one thing we always know
about the left is that you know whatever
they claim they want it's never just
that that's always that's always that is
it's only the beginning it's just it's
just what gets them in the door
and inclusion
which they shouldn't even get that okay
we should not be including males in the
category of woman because they're not
but that's not what they're looking for
what they're looking for is what you
just heard there trans Supremacy
basically
all right the daily wire has this could
the experts be starting to admit three
years later that they were wrong about
covet
at least one medical research is calling
on the scientific Community to admit
mistakes were made
Kevin bass wrote uh I was wrong we in
the scientific Community were wrong and
it cost lives he wrote this in a recent
op-ed for Newsweek for years and with
almost no voice of scientific Elites
seemingly doubled down on the almost one
voice rather the scientific leads
seemingly doubled down on the necessity
of broad vaccine mandates or prolonged
lockdowns even as Americans suffer
medical professionals who question the
narrative or offered opinions not
accepted by the mainstream were mocked
and censored on social media platforms
best of these staunchly supported Public
Health authorities when they called for
lockdowns vaccines and booster shots he
believed at the time that they were
responding with compassion diligence and
scientific expertise now the scales have
fallen from his eyes he said Public
Health authorities overstated the
evidence and misled the public on a
Litany of issues including natural
coveted immunity versus vaccine immunity
school closures and disease transmission
aerosol spread
mask mandates and vaccine Effectiveness
and safety especially for young people
bassroad
um he wrote quote if our Public Health
officials had led with less hubris the
course of the pandemic in the United
States might have had a very different
outcome with fewer lost lives
and so this guy basses is the latest
there haven't been a lot of them but
there have been a few of these uh
so-called Health experts medical
professionals who have come out and said
yeah we got this one wrong
um which is it's good for them to admit
it it's good for them to it's late it's
a little late in the game it's good to
finally admit it
the problem though is was a couple
problems first of all
this is this is not a simple uh Mia
culpa well my bad
okay
what what you went along with promoted
was the I mean the shutdown of society I
mean you you you you you you were
pushing something that had disastrous
effects on people's lives deadly effects
on people's lives and those uh
reverberations are still being felt and
will be felt for for years to come
I mean those those effects are permanent
in a lot of ways
we we live in a post-covered shutdown
world
and it's uh not like what the world
would have been had those shutdowns
never occurred and it never will be
so it's not the kind of thing that you
could just say well my bad and and and
we'll respond and say oh we forgive you
but I will say that you know I draw a
distinction
between people who were
mistaken who were
duped whatever and the people who
deliberately lied to us now this Kevin
bass person claims to be in the in the
former category he says that he himself
was duped by the medical professionals
he believed what they told him
maybe that's the case
but the real issue here
is that we were lied to
and the people who lied
and uh used those lives to lies to try
to destroy our lives
uh there can't be any forgiveness
certainly no forgetting of that
no uh as as the media has called for
pandemic amnesty there could be no
amnesty for that that's for sure so I
want to mention this also there's a
they're interesting trend on social
media in recent years where the
conversation about Leonardo DiCaprio's
famous habit of dating younger women has
devolved from jokes that people would
always make to actually accusing him of
being a sex predator
um Leonardo DiCaprio is a sex predator
for dating 19 and 20 year olds uh that
is a a widely held view now on social
media at least and it came up again this
weekend when a woman named Faye Micah
tweeted this a very viral tweet she said
at this point I can't even join in on
the jokes anymore if Leonardo DiCaprio
is approaching 50 and dating a teenager
then he's an actual sexual predator
let's be clear
and that tweet has about uh 300 000
likes
where many more you know are echoing the
sentiment as well
now
the first problem here is that you you
really are lessening the the impact of
the term sex predator when you apply it
to a man dating a legal adult any
rational person would at least agree
that there's a there's a significant
difference between Leonardo Dicaprio and
a lot of people that you find on the sex
offender registry like you're using the
same term to describe a mandating a 19
year old as we would to to describe say
a child molester and if you actually do
think that DiCaprio dating a 19 year old
is equal to a man who rapes a child that
what that really tells me is that you're
not nearly as horrified by child rape as
you should be
which is what apparently has led you to
equate the two and that's and that's
very concerning
but here's the point I really want to
make about this
the curse of the Modern Age one of them
is a total lack of intellectual
consistency
where what somebody says one minute has
no connection to what they'll say the
next minute it creates a a national
discourse that is uh schizophrenic
that just sounds insane
so consider that a great number of the
people who are to use the leftist phrase
problematizing
um DiCaprio dating 19 year olds a great
number of these people are on the left
which means that their philosophy of
consent Works something like this
a 19 year old is not old enough to fully
consent to dating a Hollywood actor
however a 15 year old is old enough to
consent to having her breasts removed
and a 10 year old is old enough to
consent to taking puberty blockers and a
three-year-old is old enough to consent
to identifying as another gender and and
can consent to a social transition
quote unquote
not only that but let's keep in mind
that 16 year olds according to left are
old enough to vote
okay we want them taking part in the
Democratic process like we want their
votes to count as much as the vote of
someone who's 30.
and they also think that middle
schoolers are old enough to obtain birth
control and and um abortions without
parental consent
and what about 19 year olds well I mean
at 19 the left would say that a person
is old enough to consent to literally
any sex change procedure at all
hysterectomy double mastectomy she can
have the skin on her arm peeled off and
turned into a fake penis
I mean life-changing and life-destroying
procedures she can consent to at the age
of 19.
and even younger
so she can enter into all of those
things with full knowledge and
discernment
and
you know we can trust her judgment when
she does
but she can't date Leonardo DiCaprio
that that's where we draw the line the
consent to all of that
but not to uh Leonardo DiCaprio
it just it doesn't make a lot of sense
of course it doesn't make sense
and what I would say is that
look if you want to take this kind of uh
minimalist sort of approach to 19 year
olds and what they're capable of
consenting to
uh then fine let's but let's let's let's
take that logic all the way to its
conclusion
because according to that logic real I
mean the voting age should be what I
mean certain not eight not even 18.
let's raise the voting age to to 30.
I mean it is true that your your brain
is not fully developed until you're 25.
um
so let's raise the vote against to at
least that to at least 25.
and what about these life changing
which is really to say life destroying
sex change procedures
I would like to ban all of them outright
but if you won't agree to that
then you should be able to agree well
let's raise let's raise that to 25 as
well
none of those procedures at all until
you're 25.
because again remember I mean 19 year
olds uh they cannot even be trusted to
decide who they want to date
so if that's the approach you want to
take
then let's just be consistent about it
but they they can't be consistent
because nothing that these people say
means anything from one moment to the
next
that's what you understand about the
left there there's there are no
precedents being set
there's no such thing as precedent
they can say you know they can lay down
one principle in one moment and then
another principle that can that that
totally contradicts that principle next
because it's just about what they need
in any given moment
and it's extremely concerning that that
also applies to Concepts like consent
the Judgment that the way that they
judge this is like what what do I need
ideologically
and ideologically
um I need to be able to say that a 15
year old girl is fully psychologically
capable of consenting to have her breast
removed for cosmetic reasons
that's what the left thinks
but when it comes to Leonardo DiCaprio's
dating habits they don't have that same
ideological need and so in that case
they can you know they could essentially
treat Leonardo DiCaprio's 19 year old
girlfriend as less capable of consent
than the 15 year olds who having the
breast removed
obviously
total total absolute incoherence
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
in case you missed it or still haven't
gotten yours last week we dropped the
newest addition to my swag Shack the
notorious SBG t-shirt over dailymire.com
shop I think I'm supposed to hold up the
surgery it's over here
um
that's not the shirt now I keep saying
that uh they're trying to get me to
promise to rap for the gang but this is
simply not the case to be clear I'm in
no way obligated to share my gifts of
inherent natural Rhythm and intricate
Rhymes all I'm saying is that I reserve
the right to withhold my talents they
just know that if I did choose to
Freestyle for whatever reason it would
be magnificent my flow is unmatched
you've already already heard a little
bit of that on the show today actually
sometimes I do you know perform pop and
rap lyrics and so you know what that
sounds like I'm gonna turn it up a
little more this time
used to dream about getting it now I got
it I don't drive so what are you waiting
for this new shirt instantly maximizes
your street cred affirms your identity
as a sweet baby gang gangster and
generally confuses the masses so go to
dailywire.com shop to get your notorious
SPG shirt today
totally ordinary says I made uh terrible
decisions as a young person it became a
stripper I believed all the feminist
crap I think these girls repeating
talking points like empowerment and my
body to cover the feelings of Shame also
the girl talking about how men solely
want to see her in particular is wrong
these men men don't care who the woman
is as long as she's available for his
viewing and checks a few boxes there
were women before her and will be a long
line after
no one will miss her
that's exactly right and and
you made terrible decisions as a young
person as many young people tend to do
um the difference between you though and
a lot of other people especially people
you're referring to here is that you
were able to uh
to acknowledge the error in your ways
and actually change whereas I think for
a lot of people this is what they get
from the culture
um
they make those terrible decisions and
then and then they believe that all they
could do is just double down and double
down
and uh and find a way to convince them
that they're you know
their self-destructive behavior is
empowering which is something that they
themselves don't believe but they'll
spend their entire lives trying to
convince them of this thing that they'll
that they'll never believe
um
Ali says I love that in this episode
Matt clarified the gender affirming
surgery is wrong regardless of age if we
say it's okay for adults then we also by
default have to admit that it's okay for
children or at least adolescents
but we don't have to say I mean there
there are plenty of things that are okay
for adults that are not okay for
children so just because locator adults
doesn't mean that um that it's
that it's okay for children
but in this particular case
um
what makes it wrong is not just that
children can't
uh you know really fathom what they're
doing and they they don't have the
ability to consent to it I mean that
that is that's part of what makes it
terrible and Evil
but also it is a fundamentally
destructive thing I mean you're
destroying your body
and and anyone who goes to a doctor
asking for this to be done to them no
matter their age
already by default can't consent I mean
the fact that you want it to be done to
you means that you're not
you know you're not in a good
psychological state
the the fact that this this desire
exists in the first place that you have
the desire to chop body parts off and
all the rest of it
it shows that there's something deeply
wrong you know there's there's a there
are some deep psychological problems
going on
and
rather than just affirming these
delusions and monetizing the profiting
off of them what we should be doing is
trying to treat
that to those psychological problems and
that's the case no matter how old you
are
um
JB says Matt I'm married I have 11
children and 22 Grand so please don't
think I'm against marriage but I met a
fellow who made the choice to become a
brother at Saint Benedict's Abbey in
Kansas lest you get the wrong picture
this man is good looking athletic has a
great personality was dating when he
felt the Lord calling him he has
dedicated his entire life to serving our
lord I can't help but admire him not
everyone is called to marriage
and I've never said that every literally
every single person is in fact I've
always mentioned that uh you know that
there are people who are called for
example to the religious life
but the important point
is that if you're called to the
religious life that is still you know as
a man if you call it to the religious
life
you're still taking on a kind of
spiritual fatherhood
so I I would argue that all men and
women are called to be
fathers and mothers and for most people
that's going to be in a literal kind of
biological sense of having kids
um
but for other people it'll come in
different forms
and one way is through the religious
life you know that's but but everyone is
called to a to uh every man is called to
a life of paternal service maybe the way
to put it
um
Jocelyn says can I be a general in the
sweet baby gang I ended an hour-long pay
pay a forward chain the worker stared at
me stared at me with hate and disgust I
just got my free chicken and left
we don't have time for this nonsense
well we don't have any Generals in sweet
baby gang there are no ranks Beyond me
there's me and everybody else so it
would be a threat to my power if we were
to promote you so we can't do that but
uh you do have my admiration especially
to do that so this was a Pay It Forward
chain at some course at a at a a
restaurant some kind of fast food
restaurant where they serve chicken I
mean usually I've only ever encountered
them at Starbucks
um
but to do this at a place where people
are buying entire meals
no you you made the right choice
I'm not just gonna sit here and like
volunteer to pay for whatever meal the
car behind me just bought
no way
all right uh Dave says Matt I saw a
video I need you to weigh in on a guy
sits next to a woman on a bus and she
yells at him and calls him creepy seems
like one of those gym video situations
except that there were a bunch of other
empty seats on the bus so why did he sit
next to her how do you rule on people
who sit closer than necessary to
strangers on public transportation all
right I think this is a video I saw the
same video on uh being passed around
social media I assume this is the video
you're talking about let's watch a
little bit of this
why are you moving foreign
the bus to start dating someone
okay no I don't I don't think it's fair
at all to compare this to the gym so now
the gym situation is a woman
looking for an opportunity to shame a
man as some sort of creep when all he's
doing is just working out he happens to
glance their Direction that's not what's
happening here at all I mean she's 100
in the right now I can't I don't know
the man's motivation for sitting next to
this woman
um we could probably guess
but yeah to when you've got an entirely
empty bus and you choose to sit right
next to a stranger
now that is never okay
um this is it does and this goes for uh
public transportation airport terminals
same principle applies to urinals and
bathroom stalls
it's like you
if you can give other people room and
personal space sometimes you can't
sometimes there's no choice if you walk
under the bus and there's and no matter
what you're gonna end up sitting next to
a person then uh then yeah just choose
for me in that in that situation it's
like a Southwest flight
and um if I'm in one of the later
boarding groups I'm gonna you have to
sit next to someone I'm going to choose
someone who's smaller and will take up
less elbow space that's what I'm going
to do but in that situation you have to
make a choice
but to sit directly next to someone when
you don't have to
is obviously creepy and weird
I mean imagine if you were at a you know
you're sitting in a food court and there
are a bunch of empty tables and then
someone sits down at your table with you
or you don't even know it's the same
kind of thing don't do that
that's hard
I've got a timely and important book to
share with you today New York Times
bestselling author Heather McDonald has
teamed up with DW books to bring you a
powerful new book which is called when
race Trump's Merit how the pursuit of
equity sacrifices Excellence destroys
Beauty and threatens lives Do You
Believe In fairness and Merit do you
care about the future of our society and
institutions that shape it than if this
book is for you if you do in Win race
trumps Merit McDonald exposes the
dangerous consequences of prioritizing
race over Merit in all aspects of
society from science to music to law
enforcement our institutions are being
eroded and destroyed all in the name of
equity this book takes a hard look at
the impact of the less pursuit of equity
and how it's undermining meritocracy and
putting our society at risk McDonald
provides a clear and sobering analysis
of what's happening and what we can
expect if we don't act if you're
interested in understanding the threat
to Western civilization and fighting
back don't miss this essential book when
race Trump's Merit hits shelves April
18th but you could pre-order your copy
today at Amazon or wherever books are
sold now let's get to our daily
cancellation
foreign
admitted that we live it that if we
lived in a sane Society not a perfect
one but merely a sane one then I
wouldn't have a job at least I wouldn't
have this job because my job at present
consists largely of saying very obvious
things things that would not need to be
said in a country where sanity reigned
uh things that if they were said in a
sane country that they'd be met with
yawning slightly bemused reactions
people would respond yeah and why are
you telling us this and they get back to
their lives but because Insanity rather
than sanity Reigns here it is necessary
to State the obvious and the obvious
when stated will nearly always be met
with screams of horror and breathless
denunciations from people who believe
that there is nothing so offensive as a
thing that is obviously true
that brings us to the latest controversy
the latest Firestorm that I find myself
in the middle of it began last week on
this show and I dedicated Thursdays I
think it was Thursday's daily
cancellation to a so-called divorce
coach who among other things advised
women that if their husbands have grown
unhappy or bitter through the course of
their marriage it's because the husband
was always an angry person whose mask
has finally fallen off
now I countered that it's certainly
possible that a man might fool his
betrothed by donning a mask which slips
during the course of the marriage
revealing his true and miserable self
however I suggested a woman who notices
that her husband is turning into such a
person would do well to consider that
his happiness might not be baggage he
secretly brought into the marriage but
rather a change that has taken place
during the marriage she should think
about whether she is giving her husband
what he most wants and needs
she'd think about whether she is helping
her husband to be happy or if she is
facilitating his unhappiness and the
good news as I explained is that the
wants and needs of a man are generally
pretty simple
what most men want is simply to come
home from work to a wife and children
who are happy to see them and grateful
for him and uh you know with dinner
cooking on the stove that doesn't hurt
either
of course as I acknowledge during the
segment not everyone's situation is
exactly the same and even in the ideal
scenario it can't be like that every day
in fact even in my specific case you
know I I really like to cook so there
are plenty of days when I cook and my
wife cleans up the dishes afterwards
um there are variations on this basic
theme variations that that also have to
account for the fact that there are
plenty of households especially in this
economy where both the husband and the
wife have to work they're forced to work
or they've decided that they have to
work
so I'm not laying out a precise
unchangeable formula that must apply to
everyone every day no matter what
rather I'm trying to explain that in
most cases
a Man simply wants to provide for his
family he wants his work and his
sacrifices to be noticed and appreciated
he wants his wife to love him and be
affectionate towards him and care for
him
and uh and respect him
and he wants his children to love him
and appreciate him and respect him and
be excited to see him
whatever exact shape this takes if a man
can have all of that he will be happy if
a man does not have that he will
probably not be happy
this is the point I made during the
segment which my team also posted to
tick tock in which I reiterated in a
tweet over the weekend
on Twitter I posted this which is what I
just said uh quote all a man wants is to
come home from a long day at work to a
grateful wife and children who are glad
to see him and dinner cooking on the
stove this is literally all it takes to
make a man happy we are simple give us
this and you will have given us nearly
everything we need
okay
Zach brings you up to speed
and then came the responses which break
down along the lines you might expect
across the platforms where we've had
this conversation
most men have answered either that they
have exactly what I described and they
love it or they aren't married yet but
they hope to have it when they are
married or they are married and they
wish they had that but instead they come
home to an unkempt unappreciative
household and a nagging wife every day
then it makes it very miserable
very few men have said that they
categorically do not desire anything
resembling the situation I described
the feminists on the other hand have had
quite a different reaction there have
been hundreds if not thousands of
Outreach well thousands actually of
outrage responses to my provocative
claim that men want to be loved and
respected by their wives and children
and um
I'll read through just a few of them a
few examples uh here's one from
notorious cat lady Jill philopovich who
tweeted get yourself doordash and a dog
and please leave women alone then she
continues this manages to be insulting
to women and men at the same time and
clearly if your husband is unhappy or
abusive it's your fault for not having
dinner ready or being sufficiently happy
anyway I'm glad to know men who actually
like women as people and want
partnership not a servile wife as Mommy
who breeds silent and compliant children
and asserts no needs of her own
Elizabeth Spears who's a democratic
consultant who made it onto the show
several months ago after writing a
column claiming that adoption is more
traumatic than abortion
she was especially incensed She Wrote
the kind of man who wants this believes
that women exist solely to serve his
needs and in relationships where that is
true the relationship is partly about
power and control a root cause of
domestic violence later she posted this
service model of relationships often
doesn't work even when women want to
play that role because Matt is an
overgrown baby and doesn't understand
that men can get all of those things and
still be abusive and cheat and be
unhappy themselves
another woman in media Jennifer Robison
who um claims to not be a feminist
posted your domestic Tableau is creepy
because it focuses only on your needs it
is you surveying your family as objects
that exist only to please you not
considering that they are discreet
humans with their own drives and desires
now there are many other responses like
this and not all from female feminists
some from even the even more pathetic
male variety of feminists and all
labeling me a sexist a caveman a
backwards abusive troglodyte stuck in
the past Etc and uh most accusing me of
making additional statements that I
never made there were also comments
sharing violent fantasies about my
family which I won't repeat suffice it
to say that we live in a deeply depraved
culture one where people lash out at
what is normal they attack normalcy
itself
and that's the first point I want to
make about all this
even if you disagree with what I said
either because you don't believe that
that's actually what men want or because
you don't think men should want it
there is no question that I was
articulating a very normal very
conventional and and very traditional
idea
one that most men through history can
relate to even prior to the Industrial
Age and the invention of the
nine-to-five job
that doesn't automatically mean that you
you can't be critical of the man as
Breadwinner Arrangement or of men who
want to come home to a loving wife and a
hot dinner I mean if you want to
criticize that sure go ahead and try
but it does make you an utterly
ridiculous and unserious person if you
treat the concept as somehow shocking
and offensive
you could try to find a reason to oppose
the way that billions of men and women
have chosen to live their lives but what
you can't do is treat it like some
freakish shocking outrageous thing
by comparison just as analogy
lots of people like Star Wars right I
don't like Star Wars now I'm free to
disagree with the tastes and preferences
of the majority of people but I would
come off like a blabbering lunatic if
someone said that Star Wars was their
favorite movie and I reacted by shouting
what are you kidding me Star Wars you
like that movie I've never heard of
anyone who likes that
in fact you might suspect that my
argument against Star Wars is rather
weak if I feel the need to
overcompensate by pretending that I'm
astonished to hear that the film has any
fans at all
but this is all the left ever does
they treat totally normal traditional
ideas and value systems as not only
wrong but appalling and bizarre
they do this because they have no real
argument against what is normal and
traditional all they have is their
theatrical protestations and they hope
that that will be enough
one other thought in this vein note that
if instead of expressing a desire to
come home to a loving wife and children
if a man instead were to you know
Express a desire to say become a
genderqueer trans woman and join a
polyamorous furry BDSM sex cult
the same people attacking him now would
instead forcefully defend the validity
of his lifestyle choices and preferences
that's because any and all desires are
celebrated by the left
unless they are normal and healthy and
traditional ones
second point
I have been criticized for discussing
what a man needs and what a man wants
without saying anything about what a
woman needs and a woman wants this has
been willfully misinterpreted as a claim
that women don't need or want anything
or that their needs and wants are
unimportant
now I of course never said that and I
don't think it I just simply didn't
mention the needs of women because that
didn't happen to be the subject that I
was speaking about at the time
okay
um just because a person is talking
about one subject it doesn't mean that
they are denying the importance of every
other subject they aren't talking about
in that moment
it is in fact okay to talk about men
without allotting equal or greater time
to a discussion about women there's
already plenty of air time taken up by
conversations about women and most of
the time when there's a discussion about
relationships it's going to be focused
on what women need
and what men need to do to fill those
needs
and yet if you spend even a few minutes
talking about the other side of that
coin you're accused of erasing or
marginalizing women
it's ridiculous
and also precisely the attitude that
makes this conversation necessary in the
first place
because the attitude for a lot of people
is that men are not allowed to talk
about what they want and what makes them
happy
women are allowed to talk about that but
men are not allowed to discuss it and if
you bring it up it is somehow offensive
you can't even talk about the needs and
wants of men without
automatically undermining the needs and
wants of women it is again totally
ridiculous and it's a game that I will
not play
third
many of my critics have taken special
exception to my use of the word grateful
um you know it's bad enough that I would
promote as they say a patriarchal and
sexist family Arrangement but it's even
worse that I would suggest that a wife
should be grateful to her husband and
for the sacrifices that he makes for the
family
this tweet from someone with a username
vmw is typical she says I'm far from
what one would call a feminist and as a
woman who was a stay-at-home mom and
does cook dinner most nights even I
objected to your grateful comment maybe
it's you who should try to try some
reevaluation of your thoughts regarding
a wife's role and motivation in marriage
well I've got some bad news for this
lady
if she doesn't think that she should
have gratitude for her husband if indeed
she thinks grateful is a dirty word
that it's highly probable that her
husband is unhappy and her marriage is
miserable a miserable drudgery for all
involved including the kids
gratitude is absolutely essential to any
happy marriage
and yes that means that the Gratitude
should go both ways
but if you hear someone say wives should
be grateful for their husbands and your
immediate response is oh yeah well what
about husbands huh they need to be
grateful too you know
if that's your response then you've
revealed yourself to be an emotional
child a self-centered brat reacting like
a three-year-old who sees that her
brother got slightly more ice cream in
her Bowl that's not fair but
that attitude is a perfect example of
what a lack of gratitude looks like in
practice
and it is absolutely toxic
fourth point
finally
rather than um
crying about the fact that so many men
desire to come home from work to a happy
and grateful family
you might take a moment to consider why
they desire it why we desire it
now it could be that we're all a bunch
of woman-hating psychopaths who hate
women so much that we married and
literally dedicated Our Lives to them
or
it could be that we are human beings who
feel that deepest of human longings to
love and be loved
we want to love our families by
providing for them we want to love them
by being useful to them
by giving them something that they need
this is why getting laid off or fired or
forced out of work for long stretches or
even retiring can sometimes be literally
deadly for a man
he feels deprived of the opportunity to
be useful
to love his family in an active and
productive way
this is what lies at the root of that
terrible evil patriarchal male urge to
be a breadwinner
what lies at the root is his desire to
give to those he loves
how awful right
what a terrible thing
and yes he also wants to be loved he
wants to know that his efforts are
noticed and appreciated
he wants a warmth and love and affection
and gratitude and respect from his wife
and if he doesn't get it he'll be
unhappy with a pain that he feels at the
deepest levels of his soul
but which he may never speak out loud
for as long as he lives
I mean a man won't usually say any of
this out loud especially these days when
he's certain to be shouted down you know
if he dare verbalize any of it
but it's the truth
and those who try to stop us from
acknowledging this truth we're talking
about it
they are the ones who are today canceled
and that'll do it for this portion the
shows move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign